[Music]
all important movies start with a black
screen movie would be amazing at cinema
sets and logos really long and dramatic
logos only movie is amazing at watching
cinema since get yourself ready for some
reading Oh movie is a fan of cinema
since also reading if you want to make
the world a better place if the movie
had just said narrating I would have
stopped the movie in the sins video
right here
shorter sins video ever job would be
done we'd have an internal discussion
about even releasing it we are
transporting 11 million sticks of
Dynamite's huh movie but this is nowhere
near 11 million of anything calling you
out on your humongous exaggeration
because I obviously hate movies way more
than I hate myself the helicopter is
about to overtake intercept and
overpower a f--king cargo jet wait it's
even worse than I thought
they being landed that chopper on top of
the airplane that man will stop you he
always stops you know he doesn't what
about that time with the two boats hmm
interesting that the pilot picks that
situation as a time Batman stopped the
Joker since it was the people on the
boats who decided not to blow each other
up and Batman had nothing to do with it
Batman's never gonna see it coming like
that time with a parade the prince music
again kind of an interesting situation
to bring up since Joker told everyone on
TV that parade was happening also while
I recognize this movie is making fun of
all the iterations of the Joker as if
they're all one continuous story I'd
like to be that dickhead who brings up
the fact that Joker died in the Tim
Burton Batman this is referencing you
know kudos to this movie for bringing
back Billy Dee Williams to play to face
when the studio decided to go with Tommy
Lee Jones back in 1995 I don't move to
since but I'm going to add one back for
still not giving him a good number of
lines
apparently it's 23 degrees in Gotham but
everyone I've seen in the movie so far
decided to just wear long sleeves and
pants outside except for the extremely
smart Commissioner Gordon you want to
get nuts 20% of this movie is called
back to previous Batman thanks beautiful
where's the bomb
but Joker already told you where the
bomb was right it was on freakin TV is
this seem funny yes is Batman's
literally playing a guitar in the middle
of fighting crime yes yes he is you
think you might grid his enemy yes
you're obsessed with me this humorous
conversation about Joker trying to get
Batman to
recognize their relationship actually
takes way longer than the time we saw
remaining on the bomb hey I know this is
a Batman spoof and literally nothing
matters but since I sent you mean
nothing to me neither does this bomb
which exploded 20 seconds ago according
to the unforgiving nature of time these
helicopters doing backflips Jesus how
many people were standing around a power
plant that was about to explode
isn't this on an island these are all
cops and plant workers are they hmm on
the shoulders ticker tape parade
celebrating Batman this is like no
Gotham I've ever seen before
Gotham hates Batman he's a vigilante box
a Batmobile exhaust fire kills hundreds
film at 11:00 despite all the future
tech in existence Batman's elevator is
slowest microwaving Lobster rich loner
or not great movie gag or not
microwaving lobsters for suckers yes it
is hilarious that Batman will have an
entire navy of vehicles but wow that
hilariousness washes over you consider
this he waited two minutes while the
lobster reheated in the microwave then
carried that reheated lobster on a tray
while he got on a jet ski and powered
the thing out of dock 23 feet then
stopped to eat a lobster yeah but where
are the amps for this guitar okay so
Batman sat down to watch Jerry Maguire
the thing is almost over
admit it you just wanted the most famous
scene to show up so everyone would know
what it is didn't you didn't you Lego
Batman is a freaking dick to Alfred
three fireplaces in one Wayne Manor room
really only three fireplaces where's the
fireplace for the fireplace since we're
in lego exaggeration movie I seen you go
through similar phases in 2016 in 2012
and 2008 and 2005 1997 1995 1992 with
1989 and that weird one in 1966 believe
me while I'm laughing my ass off the
Lego Batman movie claims that Batman is
like at least 90 years old that Alfred
must be like 130 or something Lego
Batman movie utterly retcons all Wayne
Manor location cannon in a silly pullout
joke shot your greatest fear is being a
part of a family again
nope that's a stepping stone fear to the
real theater which is losing a family
again
Alfred clearly attended the Prometheus
school of running away from things on a
psychology scholarship no Batman acts
like a literal toddler and Alfred just
rolls with it because this is regular
behavior in this universe and I'm just
saying the Batman just rolled around on
the floor like your asshole two-year-old
nice until he got what he wanted
like your asshole to you old nice
tonight Batman V Superman created a
circumstance where Gotham metropolis are
literally a few hundred yards from each
other but this is GCN Gotham City
Network and they have a popular show
called metropolis and focus Superman
tell me how do you feel about your
recent banishment of Zod to the Phantom
Zone the movie brings this up to show
that Superman cares about his
relationship with Zod unlike Batman with
the Joker but wouldn't Lex Luthor be
Superman's Joker and the movie Zod is
the one Superman always kills Lex Luthor
always ends up in jail or an asylum
always coming back for more and failing
time and again like Joker does it's not
a Batman movie if Tony Stark doesn't
attend some over-the-top garish party of
some kind but all the kids in the
orphanage call me dick well children can
be cruel why does Lego Dick Grayson need
a human being sighs pen to take notes
that pen is almost as tall as he is
we've gathered here tonight to mark the
retirement of Jim Gordon yeah but you've
gathered here tonight enough ice-skating
rink why was that again any reason at
all
who makes a King trailer for your city's
new police commissioner no one except in
Gotham City apparently also this is
Barbara Gordon daughter of Jim Gordon
and yet this movie too spent time
showing me Bruce fall in love at first
sight with her suggesting Bruce Jim
Gordon's ally for decades has somehow
never seen Gordon's daughter before this
evening which is ludicrous
the same time all the bullet points
listed on this slide are solid black
lines also the new commissioners plan
includes three normal things and
ninjutsu which microsoft word doesn't
even think is a real word he hasn't
captured Riddler
he hasn't captured Bane and this is
easily the best part of the movie
pointing out that Batman actually
doesn't do a lot of things to actually
stop crying
everyone's reactions around him are
killer this deserves a good three sins
off luckily for Joker and his get all
the super villains to surrender plan
they all decided to stand in an easily
boxa Bulow so that they could be
gift-wrapped for the good guys she
definitely upped the Miranda rights
thereby basically leaving out all but
the first line thereby ensuring all
these criminals will go free with a
half-decent we're also the only reason
this Batman all alone black and white
moment uses one as the loneliest number
is because Arrested Development had
already used sound of silence the young
orphan you adopted at the gala
remember Gotham's adoption requirements
are probably the worst thing about the
city as Batman somehow adopts this kid
with a distracted verbal agreement but
did not
acquire papers to be signed or
interviews to be conducted Lego Batman
Magic Mike I the didn't Batman just turn
this into the batplane in the first
place I mean they're going to the
fortress of solitude so that should have
been vehicle number one why did they
park so far away now you got to make you
a to the atomic caldron and get that
Phantom Zone projector it seems kind of
weird that Superman keeps the pz p in
this mission impossible esque fault at
the fortress of solitude
looks pretty inconvenient for him if he
ever has to use it and not like he has
it on him every time he goes to fight
crime as in this small Midwestern frail
bird Hey Robins are a robust species
surviving in multiple varied climates
that other dainty birds can't stand back
off the Robin bird and just make your
jokes about how Robin the character is
lame goofy and stupid leave the bird
alone it's absolutely unreal that
Superman went through all that trouble
to protect his pzp but doesn't have any
alarms that go off when it's actually
taken you could learn something from the
people who rigged that Boulder booby
trap in Raiders of the Lost Ark
did the Phantom Zone projector go it's
not under Batman or Robin escapes and
just underlines the fact that this item
is impossible to carry around
conveniently and this asshole still
doesn't have the pzp until magically
he's apparently been holding it the
whole time this is where the movie loses
me and starts to just be noise tossing
in the Wicked Witch from Wizard of Oz
Sauron gremlins agents from the matrix
King Kong Baltimore Daleks the first
lego movie at least grounded its
weirdness in that it was all the
imagination of a real human child this
movie just throws everything it can
think of into the mix and expects you to
applaud the randomness also in a
previous scene we heard about Superman
sending Zod to the Phantom Zone where
that asshole you were going to say
something about recruiting the
universe's greatest villains to conquer
a superhero how the ever-loving do you
cast the actual Baltimore in this movie
as Alfred but then hire someone else to
voice Baltimore it's the weirdest
casting decision since Courtney Love in
anything I love Eddie Izzard but the
movie misses out on some great medaka
acts with this choice why would the
Phantom Zone Gunn even have a release
all inmates setting and that's beyond
the question of why Superman even needs
a goddamn space gun to send bad guys to
the zone in the first place with a knife
or jewelry give it up
look I like this movie but this one by
one late-night talk-show introduction of
all the Phantom Zone villains is just
for us the audience literally makes no
sense in the universe of the movie that
the Joker would do this or that the
villains will all agree - we patient
need to escape back to earth so everyone
could have a proper introduction to the
humans of Gotham jeez all the
Superfriends dognition
I'm rubbing my butt all over your stuff
we're gonna have to rename this the butt
mobile smoothie had at least five
screenwriters but none of them are able
to stop this be lazy Joe from making it
into the final script they do get a
bunch of criminals together to fight the
criminals that's a stupid idea
haha for the self-awareness but too bad
Lego Batman wasn't the head of the
studio when they made Suicide Squad this
movie just got way more transformers and
furious than I think an attendant
somehow Joker had the time materials and
construction workers to turn Wayne Manor
into a theme park and in a movie with
King Kong lava-spewing Sauron and Bing
talking velociraptors the flying monkeys
from Oz will now make some kind of
impact did Batman even fix the plane
while he was out there maybe he did but
so it's running on one thing engine and
just got hit by lightning even though
this movie is silly and you can't take
even a smidgen of it seriously it
illustrates the problem with too many
villains a lot of these assholes could
end the world on their own but the movie
loses them when they're all working
together
sure killing sour on is great but you
still have Baltimore a Kraken King Kong
and others out there and you couldn't be
bothered to make a joke about killing
Sauron by throwing the One Ring into the
fires of Mount Doom so many ways you
could have gone with that but you went
with the blue fireball round Batman's
dead parents are about to ruin another
movie this whole thing is beginning to
feel a lot like the ending of Kung Fu
Panda 3 to me
Phylis shows Batman the very recent bad
things he's done and nothing from before
which is emotionally convenient to the
plot Joker you mean nothing to me
seriously his feelings toward Joker are
considered bad by the Phantom Zone pink
Phantom Zone I can't let you go my boss
will be really mad at me so if there's
this kind of hierarchy at work in the
Phantom Zone how was the pzp able to
unleash all the bad guys a few minutes
ago listen I just wanted to say that I'm
really really really every last Batman
probably has a hard time saying sorry
but even for comedic effect get on with
it already that's why I called in backup
flip flip flip flip
- Batman call all the bad guys which was
a stupid idea of course it's not the
Superfriends are the Superfriends
Justice League not a group of heroes the
Batman needs to curry favor with that
someone is defeating a crackin thing
with a giant hammer says a lot about
this movie Voldemort is trying to use
the pzp instead of you know magic to win
+ wouldn't the Phantom Zone just let
them come back anyway
shut up Joker if there's no Gotham then
I'll never get to fight you again this
Batman Joker fighting relationship an
amusing substitute for a loving
relationship officially goes too far
even in a comedy if Joker's sole purpose
is to get recognition from Batman then
what's the point of conjuring up evil
plans anymore once he gets that
recognition the plan to keep the two
plates that so Gotham together by using
sheer brute strength works we need all
of you to join us and help bring this
city back together
Oh is he broadcasting that and goddamn
every person in Gotham must be the
bravest mother for her dad ever lived to
go along with his plan I made a promise
I gotta go back to the Phantom Zone
why isn't Superman notices pzp is
missing yet Jesus show the part where
he's saying show me the money at least
all important movies end with a white
screen that's racist
[Music]
sometimes takes a little pack of
mayonnaise until squirt in their mouth
over and then she'll take an egg and
kind of she calls anim an egg
we have to stick together taken together
is what good waffles do chance of total
mission failure is 110 percent real acid
this is the illusion Michael trick is
something up or does for money Lego
Batman is not great with the healthy
snacking
I mean Batman eats microwaved leftover
lobster in the first 10 minutes of the
film that's like hitting the food
rock-bottom how much better would Lego
Batman be at his job if he had a steady
supply of healthy nutritious energy
boosting snacks delivered to his Wayne
Manor Island answer a lock if you go
right now to nature box calm and use the
code since you can receive 50% off your
first order
that's literally half off half I've got
to call you half squad lately I've
really been digging these vanilla bean
wafers they're scrumptious
but naturebox has tons of snacks to
choose from for tastes from salty to
spicy to sweet and everything in between
the problem is choice so if you need an
energy boosting snack after a night of
fighting crime don't microwave lobster
for the love of God get out instead sign
up for nature box naturebox.com/tyler
Messines
promo code sins sign up today and get
50% off your first order OMG
[Applause]